selon la légende galilée fut puni par
l'église pour avoir défendu la raison et
l'évidence de l'île centrisme par
opposition à l'enseignement catholique
qui de façon irrationnelle mettait la
terre au centre du monde pour éviter le
but chez galilée aurait reconnu s'être
trompé mais aurait doucement murmuré et
pourtant elle tourne
comment dire c'est un peu vachement plus
compliqué que ça faites ce que vous
propose de faire c'est d'imaginer un
débat sain entre deux intellectuels de
chaque camp autour des années de galilée
vear 1615 alors ça va pas être
historiquement super juste entre autres
un italien avec des yeux [ __ ] ça le
fait pas ce qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas
la vérité mais les arguments de chacun
pour justifier les positions qu'ils ont
par rapport à l'organisation du cosmos
car après tout c'est ça la science ce
n'est pas la vérité mais c'est plutôt la
recherche d'une vérité
alors comme ça tu pense encore que la
terre est au centre de l'univers
oui mais pour être clair ce n'est pas en
aristote que je crois plutôt les multi
qui ça allait mais plutôt lui mais tous
les mets était un grand mathématicien du
deuxième siècle après jésus-christ sa
grande oeuvre
sellal mage est et depuis 1500 ans c'est
la référence incontestée l'almageste a
passé le test du temps avec un succès
rare les grecs les arabes et les indiens
n'ont tous endossé c'est une théorie
formidable et comme le modèle
géocentrique de ptolémée vieux de mille
cinq cents ans n'a toujours pas été mise
à défaut par l'observation
je ne vois absolument pas pourquoi on
lui fait un procès était sûr qu'il est
si juste que ça les modèles de ptolémée
ça fait 1500 ans pour le terreau est tu
connais les tic au breuil
c'était un maniaque ce mec il a collecté
une montagne d'observation de dada voire
de bill dann attaque comme ils les
appellent
et ces dates a collé fraîchement bien
avec le modèle de ptolémée
si je comprends bien tycho brahé
proposer une alternative
en effet il proposa de dire que vénus
mars et compagnie tourne autour du
soleil qui lui tourne autour de la terre
nous pour tiko bord est le centre du
monde
c'est encore la terre ouais mais c'est
pas fini tiko vrai il est peut-être mort
avant d'avoir fini ses calculs mais il
pas et qu'il est embauché un petit génie
du saint-empire pour finir ses analyses
ah ouais c'est qui ce petit génie un
yoann s kepler je crois que c'est comme
ça qu'on est fort ouais moi non plus on
attendant rien ne contredit ptolémée tu
es vraiment fermé d'esprit en fait tu as
ta vieille théorie tu veut pas en
démordre
tu sais l'alternative l'héliocentrisme
ce n'est pas nouveau il ya 2000 ans il
ya des grecs qui ont pensé mais ça n'a
pas pris
peut-être mais enfin le modèle
héliocentrique de copernic
il est quand même vachement plus élégant
ouais ben on va quand même dans le
modèle de ptolémée
tout tourne autour de la terre
avec des trajectoires en forme d'épi
cycle et c'est à dire des cercles à
l'intérieur de cercle enfin bref un truc
vachement compliqué quoi ouais je sais
pas si tu le sais mais le modèle de
copernic a encore plus dépit ci après
vous s'est bien rendu compte que les
planètes ne tournait pas de manière
parfaitement circulaires et à vitesse
constante autour du soleil pour
expliquer cela
non seulement copernic à utiliser des
épi cycle pour accélérer ou ralentir les
trajectoires quand il le faut mais il a
même été contraint de supposer que ces
épicycle tourne autour d'un point
imaginaire qui n'est pas le soleil
sérieux le moyen de copernic n'est pas
mûr centric et non dans le modèle de
copernic
le soleil est juste à côté du centre de
l'univers
mais il n'est pas le centre de l'univers
en fait il n'est vraiment pas simple
or ce modèle de copernic pacitel le son
bouquin mais c'est un énorme pavé
ça fait mal j'avoue pire encore dans le
modèle de copernic la lune tourne autour
de la terre qui fait déjà un épicycle
autour du soleil la lune fait donc amené
pis cycle de plus dans un épais cycle
pas un truc vachement dégueu quoi et ce
qui est encore pire c'est que la lune
est la seule planète à faire ceci et ça
c'est vachement bizarre pourquoi est ce
que dans l'univers
il n'y aurait que cette seule et unique
excellent sur toi t'as pas entendu
parler de la découverte récente de
galilée je vois pas de quoi tu parles
gagné a créé une lunette c'est un espèce
d'objet pour voir super loin un
télescope comme indy bref en tout cas
avec ce télescope il a pu regarder
jupiter et l'a vu que jupiter a fait
autour de lui
des petites planètes des espèces de lune
de jupiter
je vais surtout entendu qu'il avait vu
que saturne avaient des oreilles mais
j'avoue là tu marques un point surtout
si on arrive un jour à voir que saturne
aussi à des lunes
ça ça rendrait le modèle le copernic
vachement plus crédible est en train de
basculer de quoi non faut pas déconner
là est la principale raison pour
laquelle je pense que la terre ne bouge
pas c'est juste parce que je vois qu'il
ne bouge pas enfin je veux dire toi tu
l'as ont bougé la terre non bah voilà
mais galilée a postulé le principe de
relativité
c'est quoi ça c'est une idée trop classe
le principe de relativité dit que le
mouvement et comme rien ne vient-on à
l'intérieur de la cale d'un bateau sans
fenêtre quoique ce soit il estime que le
bateau avance tranquillement en
particulier de tampa bain car il est dit
que à l'intérieur de ce bateau il n'y
aura aucune expérience que tu pourras
faire pour déterminer si le bateau est
en train de bouger ou non
les lois de la physique sont les mêmes
que l'on soit en mouvement uniforme ou
au repos
en fait sa dîme puisque sa saillie qu'il
n'y a pas de propos universel
le fait de ne pas bouger d'être en
groupe au est relatif aux référentiels
dans lequel on se place
par exemple pas part aux bateaux le mec
dans la cale du bateau lui ne bouge pas
mais nous à terre par rapport au bateau
qui bouge on bouge et donc
et donc si la terre tourne autour du
soleil eh ben ça ne change rien au fait
que nous ne bougeons pas par rapport à
la terre en fait que la terre bouge ou
non on ne devrait pas le ressentir je ne
suis pas sûr d'être 100% convaincu c'est
parce que je te dis ça comme ça c'est
même assez faux ce que je te dis
pour être plus précis il faudrait que je
te parle de mouvement rectiligne
uniforme et de forces centrifuges dans
un référentiel en rotation mais league
et lille et ce qu'il dit a beaucoup de
sens tu me perturbe
c'est vraiment intéressant tout sort
la parallaxe stellaire dacquois la
parallaxe stellaire jour a dû y penser
plus tôt
c'était l'argument clé d'archimède pour
défendre le géocentrisme archimède le
savant grec
oui le plus grands mathématiciens de
tous les temps pour le coup archimède
tout ce qu'il vit ça vaut de l'or et son
argument pour le jeu centrisme juste
implacable et c'est quoi cet argument à
ligne t2 doit les faire mieux à gauche
le doigt de derrière va être à droite du
doigt devant maintenant fermé droite et
celle inverse que tu vois le droit de
derrière et maintenant à gauche
et ça c'est parce que avec chacun de nos
yeux ou d'un angle de vue différent sur
les doigts c'est ce qu'on appelle la
parallaxe
c'est grâce à ça que tu vois en 3d pour
l'instant jusqu'à sion mais si la terre
tourne autour du soleil entre mars et
septembre où devra avoir deux angles de
vue différents sur l'univers et du coup
on devrait voir les étoiles différemment
spike là non archimède a minutieusement
étudié les étoiles de l'univers
il a montré qu entre mars et septembre
leur disposition dans le ciel était le
même il a même fait des calculs montrer
qu' étant donné ces appareils de mesure
les le centrisme serait tenu à bhl que
si ces étoiles se trouve plus de 1000
fois plus loin que saturne un truc
débile quoi
ça ça n'a pas de sens l'univers ne peut
pas être aussi qu'on voit que vérifier
tout ce que tu dis mais je crois que tu
m'as convaincu
la dernière fois on a parlé de la loi 2
d'accord mais aussi d'épistémologie de
l'importance de la consistance des
théories et chaque mot nous demande si
la théorie de newton est consistante et
ça c'est une très grande question elle
vient faut dire que les équations de
peine avec son thème vachement
incomplète
dans un souci on me donne juste f égalem
à ça suffit pas il faut aussi connaître
quelles sont les forces qui existent
dans la nature notamment les forces
électromagnétiques où il force de
gravité ceci dit une fois que l'on a
déterminé les forces de la nature
il reste encore à essayer de démontrer
qu'elle ne prédisent au plus qu'un seul
futur
et ça c'est un point assez difficile que
l'on peut relier à celui de coaching
chine ajouté aux âmes de kosice si vous
l'avez vu qui garantit sous certaines
conditions d'existence et l'unicité d'un
unique futur prédit par la théorie de
newton donc temps que les hypothèses de
cocher les fuites sont vérifiées on peut
dire que la théorie de newton et
consistante
à condition bien sûr que les
mathématiques aussi son consistante qui
est tout une question encore plus
difficile avec le temps de la compétiton
gazelle et tout ça ceci dit on peut dire
qu'on a quand même vachement plus
confiance en la consistance de la
théorie de newton pour cette d'aristote
de temps on a prouvé qu'elle était
inconsistante tuto remarque que j'avais
fait lanières fois sur les périmètres
des cercles en géométrie hyperbolique
eysseric au lift off lui remarquer que
richert taille et a fait des vidéos à ce
sujet allez les voir richard taille
haies et juste génial j'adore ce mec qui
part qu'il faut s'accrocher un peu plus
parce que ce qui fait richard pc des
vrais cours alors que là ce qu'on fait
c'est la vulgarisation très simplifié
vous attendre à dire que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo où la chaîne en général je
suis ça me fait super plaisir
je n'ai peut-être que 500 abonnés mais
les 500 abonnés que j'aime ou en tout
cas ce qui m'a découvert je vous adore
vous êtes juste géniaux j'espère que
vous avez aimé cet épisode alors à
travers cet épisode j'espère vous avoir
montré trois choses
vous invite à y réfléchir davantage
après cette vidéo la première c'est
qu'il ya plein de choses que l'on prend
pour acquis qu'ils ne sont enseignés à
l'école comme des vérités évidentes qui
ne sont vraiment pas le fait que la
terre n'est pas au centre de l'univers
c'est un truc qui est vachement pas
évident et puis qui est même en fait je
dirais faux dans le cadre de la
relativité générale puisque la terre
suis un géodésie donc va tout droit à
travers l'espace temps et donc ne tourne
pas désolé galilée la deuxième chose
c'est que les séances est quelque chose
qui se construit au fur à mesure du
temps qui se débat qui se roder bas et
les arguments d'un jour ne seront
peut-être plus valable lendemain il peut
y avoir des nouvelles observations de
nouveau des idées qui apporte de
nouveaux arguments
c'est comme ça que se construit des
sciences c'est quelque chose de
dynamique et qui est absolument pas figé
dans le marbre
la troisième chose c'est que lorsque
vous avez des débats moi je trouve ça
toujours beaucoup plus intéressant de
chercher à comprendre ce que l'autre dit
à comprendre son point de vue et a
essayé de raisonner en termes de son
point de vue et puis montrer comment un
autre point de vue peut permettre de
remettre en cause ou de doro réfléchir à
certains trucs plutôt que de chercher à
avoir raison je trouve que beaucoup trop
souvent dans des débats notamment à la
télé dans les procès entre avocats ou
autres des hommes politiques le but du
jeu trop souvent c'est d'avoir raison
alors qu'avoir raison que si on a raison
pour les mauvaises raisons ça ça je vous
conseille vivement un article 2 au chili
sur le web in et de curiosité à ce sujet
sur le sujet de l'île au centrisme qui
va même jusqu'à suggérer que l'argument
héliocentrique et c'est l'argument
religieux à l'époque puisqu'il se pose
est que l'hiver a été un très très grand
et qu'elle était subordonnée tout était
jolie du coup il y avait un créateur en
tout cas je suis un petit bisou à mes
amis de vidéos science et de vodka
science qui m'ont amené à écrire cet
épisode si vous avez mes pensées à liker
a commenté à partager cet épisode c'est
comme ça que cette chaîne pourra
peut-être décoller pensez à vous abonner
pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes
et j'espère que je vous verrai la
prochaine fois si la terre tourne autour
du soleil
alors les étoiles devrait avoir une
parallaxe autrement dit vous êtes
littéralement et scientifiquement au
centre de votre univers